on this vote the yeas are 254 the nays
are 175 the motion is adopted the u.s
government will remain open at least
until early december democrats and some
republicans came together on thursday
hours ahead of a midnight deadline and
with this continuing resolution we not
only keep government open keep checks
flowing to
uh to our veterans and social security
recipients and the rest it's just a
remarkable thing to think of all the
things that we can do working together
for the people
but while congress has put out one fire
yet another blaze threatens the
country's financial solvency it's the
nation's looming debt ceiling the point
at which the u.s can borrow no more
money to pay its bills
that limit will be reached on october
18th unless congress agrees to raise or
suspend it economists including treasury
secretary janet yellen say a u.s
government default will likely throw the
u.s economy into recession and
destabilize global markets
it's necessary to avert a catastrophic
event for our economy
representatives the debt ceiling has
been raised or suspended 78 times since
1960 almost always on a bipartisan basis
my hope is that we can work together to
do so again
republicans raised the debt ceiling
three times under former president trump
but have vowed against doing the same
for president biden
that leaves democrats with the task of
solving the issue alone requiring
challenging parliamentary maneuvers with
no guarantee of succeeding in time
republicans need to get out of the way
so senate democrats can address the
issue quickly and without needlessly
endangering the stability of our economy
we cannot afford the risk of a drawn out
unpredictable process republicans though
refuse to budge they say it's the
democrats problem because they control
government we're able to fund the
government today because the majority
accepted reality
the same thing will need to happen
on the debt limit next week
another week another display of the
partisan acrimony accompanying the u.s
congress from crisis to crisis
heidi jo castro al jazeera washington